hello my name is David silver and I lead
the C++ nano degree program at Udacity
and we are super excited to talk with
you today about what the nanodegree
program covers what we teach who's
teaching it and the projects that you'll
do as part of the program so so I'll
start off by talking about the program
at a high level the program is a five
month nanodegree program each month
spent on a different topic the first
month is spent on the foundations of C++
the second month is spent on
object-oriented programming in C++ the
third month is spent on memory
management in C++ and the fourth month
is spent on concurrency in C++ the fifth
month are really more like half of a
month is spent on a capstone project
which is an independent project that you
will do using all of the different
skills that you've learned or at least
many of the different skills that you've
learned as part of the nanodegree
program this program is designed for
software engineers who already know how
to program but are interested in
learning C++ to sue one of the many
different career lines and types of jobs
that require C++ C++ is a fairly old
language this is actually its 40th
birthday or anniversary this year was
created in 1979 but it's really
undergone a kind of renaissance in the
last few years both because of updates
that have been made to the language to
make it a more modern language and also
because of the importance of c++ for
running on embedded hardware and real
time systems things like self-driving
cars or drones or medical equipment or
any type of electronics or a system that
requires super fast performance and
needs to run very close to the hardware
that actually describes a lot of
different types of software applications
these days so we're excited to teach C++
each month of the nanodegree program is
taught by a different instructor but a
couple of the people who will be kind of
consistent across the entire program are
myself and BR nistru strep who is the
creator of C++ the RNA appears in
multiple different points throughout the
nanodegree program to talk about wine
which developed the way it did how
students might think about developing
c++ and how he thinks about using
different features of the c++
programming language B Arnott is the
creator of C++ he is still very very
active in the development of C++ and
he's been very gracious in sharing his
knowledge with students of C++ both in
this program and in many other programs
Barron has a number of textbooks that
are all terrific about the C++
programming language and he spent 12
years as a professor teaching C++ as
well so with with those that kind of
background leading into the program
let's talk about what will go on in each
of the months of the C++ nanodegree
program so the first month of the
program covers the foundations of C++
and this is taught by my Udacity
colleague Steven Welch that's Steven
right there
Steven has worked together with me for a
long time at Udacity first on the
self-driving car engineer nano degree
program and then on other programs we've
developed and he is the primary teacher
for the first month of our C++
nanodegree program and Steven will be
teaching you concepts like input and
output IO and C++ control flow so things
like conditionals and loops functions on
how to use tools from the standard
library in different classes and objects
that you wouldn't stand sheet from the
standard library he and B are knit
together we'll talk about the C++ core
guidelines which is a really long set of
guidance for how to write high-quality
modern C++ code he'll also introduce
some concepts that you'll need for the
the project the final project for this
month each month has a final project so
you'll need to learn about pass by
reference which is a particular way of
passing variables between functions and
C++ you'll also learn about different
build tools like make and see make in a
couple of different compilers that
you'll use to compile C++ C++ as you may
or may not know is a compiled
programming language which is different
than a scripted programming language
like say Python C++ is compiled down to
executable code before you run it and
then then you run it once you've built
the executable and so it's actually a
two-step process compile and then
execute and you'll learn about that in
this foundations month and this is
designed this month is really designed
to get everybody up to speed with the
basics of C++ so we can progress with
more advanced C++ topics so the project
at the end of this month is um is
building a route planner using Open
Street Map Open Street Map is a data set
that has data about really the entire
world and about all the streets and pads
and places in the world and it allows
you to build a Google Maps style
interface you can we'll teach you how to
use some graphics libraries to put
together a Google Maps style output and
then to use the a-star planning
algorithm to plot a route around a real
city this is actually the city of Austin
Texas
in the view from Texas may or may not
recognize this street grid here this is
the Texas State Capitol this is actually
the map that we use for the project at
the end of this first month of the
program but you could also apply this to
lots of other map data for any place in
the world that you might want to not
route a map between so if you've ever
wondered how when you pull up your phone
the computation is done to figure out
the fastest route between where you are
in your destination you'll get to
implement that at the at the end of the
first month of this of this program so
that's the first month of the program
foundations of
plus plus the second month of the
program is object-oriented programming
in C++
now of course object-oriented
programming is a generic approach to
programming generic in the sense that it
it's not language specific many many
different types of languages support
object-oriented programming this course
will be taught by urban crepin äj-- who
is a C++ instructors he's also taught a
number of other courses in lots of
different places and ermine will be
introducing you both to the general
concepts of object-oriented programming
but more specifically how to implement
those concepts in C++
so this is really a class about this
course this one-month course on
object-oriented programming in C++ is
really about how to do object-oriented
programming in C++ and probably less
about object-oriented programming more
generally so erm and will teach you
things like or teach students things
like classes which are the foundation of
object-oriented programming in C++
constructors and destructors so how do
we instantiate and then destroy objects
of a particular class access modifiers
how do we data within a class from
unintended or malicious access
initialization lists which are part of
modern C++ and how how you initialize
the members of a class when you
instantiate it and then he'll teach how
to perform basic object-oriented
programming concepts or implement basic
objects or name programming concepts in
C++ so things like encapsulation and
abstraction so how do you encapsulate
data within a class and how do you
abstract away the data and and the
functions you perform on that data so
that all the user of the class has to
know is what the interface to the
classes and not B internals of the class
structure
he'll also teach inheritance and content
which are two ways to relate classes to
each other a class can inherit from a
parent class or it can be composed of
other classes and and will you'll learn
about
both of those patterns work in C++
you'll also learn about polymorphism
also about templates and these are some
of the tools that C++ uses to implement
what's called generic programming so you
can use things like polymorphism and
templates to allow say a class to accept
many different types of arguments or a
function to accept many different types
of arguments with one function signature
in that way your code in Eric it can
accept lots of different types of
arguments and there are there are other
applications of generic programming as
well that the an object of the class can
be used in many different ways and this
is really important for modern C++ and
so you'll learn about that and in this
course and at the end of this course
you'll implement a process manager
assistant manager in C++ this is a
screenshot of the of the system manager
on olymic it's called H top you'll build
a slightly simplified version of H top
as part of the final project or as the
final project for this object-oriented
programming
of course you'll use C++ to pull lots of
data about the Linux 5 out of out of
Udacity machines we give you at Udacity
an online Linux desktop that you can
program on so you could either develop
this on your own Linux machine if you
have one or on the Linux desktop you can
access and code on through through the
browser as part of the Udacity
nanodegree program you'll implement a
code to read files Linux manipulate the
data you get from those files and you'll
use the end curses library to output
information about those files and create
a the type of terminal based graphical
process manager that you see here that
was out all the different types of
processes that are running on your
system and how much memory and CPU and
in other resources those processes on
the system are consuming so those are
the first two months of the course
foundations of C++ and object
to programming in C++ the third month of
the program is memory management also
taught by urban crépinette memory
management is extremely important to C++
in a way that is probably less
noticeable in a lot of other languages
many other languages have garbage
collectors and take other steps to
abstract away memory and resource
management so that programmers don't
have to spend as much time thinking
about how to acquire and then release
resources in C++ a lot of that work is
done either explicitly or implicitly by
the programmer and that's part of what
allows C++ to run very very fast and
very close to hardware is that the
programmer is designing the program or
the engineer is designing the program to
account for and allocate and release
resources as opposed to some sort of a
global garbage collector getting run in
the background so part of a major part
of memory management C++ involves
pointers which are variables that point
to memory addresses you tend to work
with memory addresses and C++ much more
directly than in many other programming
languages references are are another way
to think of memory and memory addresses
references are are essentially a memory
address or they're they're a variable
that represents a memory address whereas
pointers are the things that are
variables that point to memory addresses
but both of these are important for
working directly with memory as opposed
to copying variables and lots of
different instances depending on the use
case it can be much more efficient to
pass around a reference or a pointer to
a memory address than to make a deep
copy of all of the data inside of a
class or an object we'll also talk about
scope which is extremely important when
when thinking about memory management
and resource allocation C++ does not
have a garbage collector but the
compiler will design the program so
when a variable goes out of scope all of
the memory from that used by that
variable or type is released
automatically and so understanding when
their variables in scope and when it
goes out of scope is is really important
when thinking or when writing a C+
program along with that is a a in
acronym called re III this is something
developed by VR in a strip back when he
invented C++
BR now says he's the worst marketer in
the world because almost anybody could
have come up with a better name than REI
REI stands for resource acquisition is
initialization it's kind of another way
of thinking about scope essentially when
you acquire resources for a variable
when you declare a variable or when you
instantiate an object of a class that's
when you're acquiring resources and you
should already be thinking about when to
release them so that you know you've
initialized the variable when you
acquire the resources and then you
already understand when that variable or
when that memory or those resources are
going to be released we also learned
about static versus dynamic memory
dynamic memory sometimes thought of as
the heap static memory sometimes as the
stack these are concepts about
computational architecture more
generally but particularly related to
C++ depending on how you declare and
initialize a variable you may get the
memory from different places it may be
faster or slower you may have to think
harder or not at all about how to
release that memory so that you don't
have memory leaks it's a really
important concept to understand when
you're writing code in C++ you'll also
learn about smart pointers which are a
new type of pointer that C++ has made
available just in the last few years
that are in some ways more intelligent
than draw pointers these are pointers
that the compiler compiles the program
to keep track of automatically so that
it's kind of a weak form of garbage
collection so that you don't
up with dangling pointers or memory
leaks so easily and memory leaks are a
really important topic to think about
when you cover memory management in C++
because as you're managing all of this
memory yourself it's easy to declare
memory and then forget to release it to
acquire resources including memory and
forget to release it or or destroy those
resources when you're done and that can
lead to a degradation in performance and
memory weeks over time the the project
at the end of this month is to implement
your own version of smart pointers I
can't I don't have a great visual for
the head project so I don't have a slide
for that although we're working on
finding a way to take that project which
is really a kind of system design or
language design project and give it a
little bit of a visual output so that
you have something kind of neat to to
visualize the work that you've done in
designing smart pointers VR&E talks a
lot about how how as a language designer
he's always very jealous of the robotics
and the computer graphics engineers
because they always have terrific demos
but when you're designing something like
a operating system or a language your
demos are often a lot more muted and a
lot of the work you've done is kind of
silent or behind the scenes not visual
but hopefully we can we can come up with
a good visual for for this project so
those are the first three months of the
course we have foundations of C++ object
oriented programming in C++ and memory
management the fourth month of the
course is parallel algorithms including
oh sorry is concurrency and this is
taught by Husan al Rubio who is an
engineer C++ engineer in New York State
has taught a number of courses in C++
Huseyin will be teaching about parallel
algorithms about processes threads these
are all different ways to run different
code in C++ in parallel so you could
start with parallel algorithms which are
simply implementations of algorithms in
the standard library that run
well and you kind of get that
acceleration for free is a developer
because other people have written the
code already processes and threads are
different ways to spawn lines of
execution on your operating system
processes are a little more heavy weight
and as Moore's Law kind of run into a
number of physics problems as the rate
at which processors accelerate his has
slowed down on any one processor because
of heat and other constraints one way
that a lot more performance out of
computers is having multi-core
processors so instead of running one
line of execution very very fast on a
processor you might run for eight or
sixteen lines of execution almost as
fast but because you're running you know
eight or sixteen of them at a time if
you design your program right if you
design it to be concurrent then you can
have lots of different lines of
execution all running at the same time
and you can get a pretty dramatic
acceleration in programming performance
so that's the fourth month of the
program and that's the final month of
instruction and the project for this
month will be cellular designing a
cellular these are graphical agents that
you can spawn you can spawn lots of them
and they can all run kind of
independently and they can create write
to a file that will create a kind of
abstract art almost with each agent kind
of making its own decisions about how it
how it contributes to the overall file
or structure that's being designed and
it's a really neat way to run lots of
different threads in parallel and also
visualize what each of those threads are
doing and how that comes together into
an aggregate program output the file so
the program will be the capstone project
this is something designed by all of
Udacity that's my picture there David
silver but this is really designed by a
number of different colleagues of mine
who are all working together to help
build this this program and the capstone
project is in independent
for you to complete it's not designed to
be enormous it's not a you know a PhD
dissertations designed just to be a
couple-week project that you do using
the information that you learn the
skills you gained over over the month of
learning about C++ or sorry the four
months of what students really really
like and so we're rolling it out across
many of our nano degree programs that
you have this kind of independent
project almost that's a little bit
unique to you and and we hope it works
out really well for our c++ students so
that's that's the end of the
presentation we'll shift now to QA and
I'm delighted and excited to answer any
questions that that any of you have
about the nanodegree program or about
C++ or about Udacity or me or life or
whatever you want to ask so I think one
of my colleagues is teeing up a bunch of
those questions from from the chat and
I'm excited to to address them let's see
what what do we have we have the first
is jet Ecco asks how is this nano degree
different than the C++ for programmers
free class that's a great question
particularly because at least right now
when you search for Udacity C++ the the
free classes the first thing that pops
up that class is is several years old
and so it's got a little more Google
power behind it SEO power but it's a
much shorter class the free class it was
designed actually by a different
colleague of mine Katherine gembo who's
terrific is no longer at Udacity but she
designed it several years ago as a quick
introduction to C++ for programmers the
intent of the of both programs is the
same - to help teach people who are
ready software engineers to write C++
the C++ for programmers course is much
shorter it's a little bit I guess you
might call it a little incomplete in the
sense that the answer is we're not
covering C++ 20 there are a few times
particularly in in different places and
it talks in the course where he talks a
lot about C++ 20 C++ 20 is the next
major release of C++ that actually comes
out
next year it includes a number of major
features I actually have an interview
with Baroness through strep it's a
little bit separate than from his
teaching in the nanodegree program this
interview will I think launch or we'll
release it in the next few weeks I
filmed that in New York with him last
week and he was talking a lot about C++
20 and particularly concepts which are a
language feature related to to generic
programming that are releasing in C++ 20
we made the decision for this course to
focus on C++ 17 because that's the
standard that supported by all major
compilers right now whereas C++ 20
different things are supported in
different compilers everything BR nough
says in C++ 20 is supported on some
compiler but GCC some features clang
supports other features Microsoft's
compiler supports other features so
instead of teaching a standard that's
not yet current what we'll teach the
most current standard and then we'll you
know well upgrade the course when C++ 20
is released David asks does concurrency
cover GPU programming that is also
another great question um the answer is
is that we focus concurrency simply on
on the C++ specific language features
that are relevant primarily for CPU
acceleration acceleration GPU
acceleration often involves relying on
things like CUDA or OpenCL which are a
couple of different standards outside of
C++ that that enable acceleration on a
GPU there are a few different things
that that complicate that one you have
to have a GPU and other is you have to
learn these kind of standards that are
above and beyond normal C++ so it's
possible we may cover GPU programming in
another nanodegree program of course at
some point I think that's super exciting
we debated whether to cover it for this
program but there's a lot to cover in
concurrency simply around the parallel
algorithms and processes and threads and
multi-threaded programming and thread
synchronization more
than enough to cover in one month on
concurrency and I'm pretty excited that
we're teaching it just enjoying music
asks can somebody with basic programming
knowledge not coding on a daily basis
make it in this program that is a great
question you know if if three years that
Udacity has taught me anything it's that
determination to learn a topic often
Trump's the the prerequisite knowledge
that somebody comes in with we've seen
people be successful in very advanced
programs with relatively light
engineering backgrounds or programming
backgrounds if they are really really
determined to make it through the
program that said this this nanodegree
program is designed for people who are
already software engineers or software
programmers who are looking to translate
their knowledge of other languages to
C++ and so we move pretty quickly
particularly through that month on
foundations we don't spend a lot of time
you know thinking too hard about what
does an if/else block do or how to
functions work generally we we kind of
assume that that's background knowledge
people are pretty comfortable with him
and we simply say you know here's how
you you do these things in C++ and so if
you have a relatively light programming
background you might consider starting
with our intro to programming nanodegree
or even our intro to self-driving cars
in the under degree program which is a
little more advanced than that and
getting a little more programming
experience under your belt and then when
you feel pretty comfortable as a
programmer in a language like Python or
JavaScript or Java or any one of a
number of other languages than this C++
native we program is really designed for
someone at that level
Shelley asks will it be possible to do a
capstone project building some sort of
interactive interactive graphics app
graphics app using OpenGL probably on
references and smart pointers a lot of
modern C++ involves avoiding pointers
raw pointers can be dangerous and hard
to keep track of and be our news crews
chip himself will say that if you're
using a lot of raw pointers then you
might be doing something wrong and so we
spend a lot of time on things like
references
and pointer references and smart
pointers and scope and and how do you
use some of the features of the language
and the compiler to do memory management
for you rather than doing a ton of of
messing around with Raw pointers but we
do spend you know a little bit of time
talking about pointers and references
and going through a lot of different
examples about how you create a pointer
dereference a pointer relate a pointer
to a reference and things like that
let's see let's see Gaga also says just
finishing the class and c++ would cover
the foundations including STL which is
the standard library I started learning
concurrency allocators type traits do
you think this class will give me more
on top I think so I guess it depends a
little bit on you what your your
previous class covered and how thorough
it was I will say one of the things
about Udacity that we pride ourselves on
is just the amount of code that we set
up for students to write we have this
saying at Udacity that you don't lose
weight by watching other people exercise
if you want to become a C++ engineer you
really need to write the code yourself
and that's true for any type of
engineering work you want to do that
that's saying you don't lose weight by
watching other people exercise comes
directly from Sebastian Thrun our
founder who wrote a lot of the C++ that
created modern self-driving cars and so
depending on you know what class you
took you may or may not have written
quite a bit of C++ you certainly will
write a lot of C++ if you enroll in this
in an interview program and one of the
things we do is we we we don't cover
everything you might imagine you could
cover in in four and a half months
because we spend a lot of time building
exercises and projects you know if all
you're doing is watching videos for four
and a half months you can watch a lot of
videos but then you get to the end and
you may not actually really know how to
write code in this class you may watch
fewer videos and spend a lot more time
writing code
how will the project's be structured are
we given skin code so we're going to
rebuild the projects from scratch
following the given requirements that's
a great another great question we tend
to build most of our projects from
scratch you know we don't want to set
students up with too many projects where
we give them so much skeleton code that
the student finishes
a project and they feel like they didn't
actually really do the project
themselves or they couldn't recreate it
because they don't know how all this
skeleton code work in some cases where
their skeleton code that's repetitive or
for some reason you know it doesn't
really make sense to have students spend
a lot of time on that we might give
students some code and say here's how we
design this you can use this code if you
want or you can rewrite it yourself from
scratch but most of the projects you're
kind of building from the ground up
let's see Pericles asks can you please
speak more to applications of C++ and
how C++ differs from other languages
it's common uses and future C++ is what
I can think of is that what I think of
as a compiled high-performance
programming language
I think of C++ is the type of language
and maybe the primary language that you
might use if the performance and
execution velocity of your code is a
primary concern if if the primary
concern is as often the case is how long
it takes a developer to write the code
then you might choose another language
like Python on that or JavaScript or or
many other different types of languages
that are maybe a little bit easier and
quicker to write but maybe don't run
quite as fast but when you're running
code particularly in a
resource-constrained environment that
has to run very quickly um I think this
is a course that will teach you how my
my colleague running the the video
stream says we lost my answer on on the
question about the game industry so I'll
just repeat that real quick I think this
nanodegree program could be really
helpful to somebody working looking to
work in the game industry a lot of game
engines and physics engines are written
in C++ because of the need for super
high performance I mean also the need to
leverage GPUs and a lot of GPU code is
written in C++ we don't teach game
engine specifically in this program we
don't teach how to work with game
engines like unreal or unity or other
engines but but we do teach how to
become a good C++ engineer and that's
really important for
in a lot of different roles in the
gaming industry or game industry I guess
I should say gaming industry often means
gambling which could be useful for Pitt
but that's a different question
Tori asks can you expand on what level
of programming skill you recommend for
taking this class I can hack together
scripts but I'm not a great programmer
sometimes I feel that way too I think
the this this nanodegree program is
targeted at the same type of student who
might enroll in our robotics or our
machine learning or our self-driving car
near degree programs these are people
who you know aren't necessarily software
wizards but they are comfortable
developing software if if the idea of of
writing a larger program that maybe has
a number of classes and and some
interfaces between the classes if that
type of idea seems a little bit
overwhelming to you then a program like
our intro to self-driving cars our intro
to programming nanodegrees is a great
way to get started as well as some of
our more application-specific nanodegree
programs like say our our full stack web
developer nanodegree is another great
way to get more programming experience
but if you feel pretty comfortable like
writing a few classes and in developing
you know some some interfaces for those
classes then I think then I think you're
ready to take the C++ standard degree
program we certainly don't expect you to
be you know you know in the top 1% of
software engineers anywhere you know we
want this to be an accessible class we
also you know want it to be a class that
really helps people who are comfortable
with software engineering and make turns
you into a really good C++ engineer
antal says I have a front-end degree but
I want a better understanding of
programming principles and to get some
skills that are useful in some way in
the web development field would you
recommend this degree that's hard I
guess I would say if what you are
looking for at Udacity is a better
understanding of web development more
generally our full stack nano degree is
terrific as our
Aria are as is our react nanodegree
program and we're building I believe
some other programs in that vein that
are super useful C++ as I mentioned is a
language that some companies are
rewriting their their web applications
in because you know at massive scale
performance becomes really important and
so if you're interested in becoming a
C++ engineer at a company that is doing
that at a company often that has massive
amounts of traffic on their on their web
applications and then this would be a
super useful nanodegree program but if
you're you're interested in becoming you
know your kind of normal web developer
and you know developing websites and
different types of frameworks or like
node or react or angular then this isn't
really of course that covers that we're
really covering the C++ programming
language in this course in JavaScript
and Python and I guess in the battle
days PHP and perl where are some of the
languages that are more relevant to
those types of web frameworks max asks
are the whole content and all projects
accessible from the start of the program
in May or are they still being created
like it what like it was in the case of
the self-driving car nanodegree max you
sound like you are a an experienced
Udacity student that is a great question
and the answer is we are still building
out the the memory management and
concurrency courses in the nanodegree
program so both the the foundations
course and the object-oriented
programming course and projects will be
available at launch the memory
management and concurrency courses
should be available within I would guess
a few weeks after launch we're pretty
close on those but I think we probably
will launch as is often the case at
Udacity without everything being it
being quite buttoned up and and we
should be able to finish everything you
know within a relatively short timeframe
after we launch the program Steve then
and this is the last question what is
the job demand for C++ engineers there
are so many jobs for C++ engineers that
is a great question because
C++ is a skill that so many different
employers are are looking to hire for
and it's it's actually become a little
bit of a hard skill to find particularly
for what's called modern C++ you know a
lot of people were in C++ at least a lot
of people my age and this kind of
reminds me that I'm not as young as I
used to think I was a lot of people
learned those engineers are hard to find
and a lot of embedded systems
applications Internet of Things robots
automotive applications not only
self-driving cars but also just normal
automobile development surgical robot
surgical development machine learning
even artificial intelligence is a really
important domain for C++ engineers
because you know while you might train
your machine learning models using own
language like Python once it's time to
deploy that language you often want to
use C pasta ploy it depending on you
exactly what type of system you're
deploying it on and it's relatively hard
to find engineers who are trained in
both things like machine learning and
deep learning but also have C++ skills
so that's another area where if you have
kind of a mix of skills you can be
really really valuable but the the kind
of summary version of that is there are
a lot of layers looking for C++
engineers which you can find if you just
go to a job search engine and type in
C++ you know there all sorts of
different applications games are another
one that came up where employers are
looking for people who know C++ I was I
saw that we lost the the start of this
answer on the stream I apologize for the
the streaming difficulty so I'll just
repeat the start of the answer by saying
this is a great question and the answer
is that lots of employers are looking
for C++ engineers particularly modern
C++ engineers a lot of people around my
age learn C++ in the late 90s or early
2003 mning languages a lot of people who
started learning to code after that
never learned C++ because they jump
straight to languages like Java or
Python or JavaScript a match of skills
or mix of skills for employers to find
in one that lots of employers oh I hope
you're excited about C++ and and
hopefully even about the nanodegree
program but I am really
excited about about teaching and being
involved in this program I've learned a
lot just through developing the program
with great instructors and also with be
honest drew strip who's been very
gracious with his time and in helping to
advise us on how to structure the
program and also helping to to talk a
little bit in the program and explain
you know why things are the way they are
in C++ that you will really really enjoy
the program as well and I hope you
enroll and join us in the classroom see
you soon